choupette était sage ce week-end pour se
laisser admirer pour marquer sa dixième
édition le festival l'ombre d'un cours a
fait appel au souvenir des cinéphiles
etc les fils des animations et des
projections le coeur du festival deux
jours de projection avec un jury spécial
là aussi des souvenirs et une petite
nouvelle cette année on a voulu un jury
spécial c'est à dire on a fini nous
faire appel aux anciens présidents et
président du jury depuis 2010 et donc
nous avons alexis de sow qui est venu en
2015 catherine benguigui en 2013 nous
avons brigitte le cordier qui étaient là
en 2010 et nous allons gérard de salles
qui étaient là en 2016
on a vu pas mal de films sympa différent
il ya des choses très intéressantes donc
on va aller en parler avec le jury puis
encore une autre session après donc
voila mais oui on a vu des belles choses
en tout cas cette année 44 films étaient
en compétition avec des réalisateurs
venus parfois de loin
comédie boustany artistes iraniens et
son court métrage sur la justice
[Musique]
[Rires]
je voulais être ici parce que je voulais
que mon film soit présenté à des
étrangers
pour connaître les avis sur mon film
pour la 11e édition le festival fêtera
ses dix ans les équipes planchent déjà
sur les candidatures